okay so if you want to polish way but
flow Honka Honka wha and lancaster board
over but you can call me again okay you
can try this and feel sampler okay
alright so this is a physicist technique
by the way right if something is too
hard you just remove it let's start
let's start things in the physics way
sir so we have been asked with lenka to
talk about the kind of physics viewpoint
on while you know parson function
sampling and counting and all that and
we started by a hugging what we should
do because I mean we could see that we
are ready to different talks entirely
different talks that we could give and
of course you have to choose I mean it's
a very bad idea to give to toxic one
talks so we decided to do it anyway no
hope it will be okay and you will see
the first one so that's me the first
part will be really like partition
functions something evil in physics and
what I want to do is to say look I will
put my physics huts like a okay I'm a
physicist this is what we do that's
that's the kind of thing I want to tell
you like what my friends in my
department do and ok and then lenka
wants to say something already a bit
different we say ok which is the same
outside physics and this is more like
okay you know we physicists have been
walking in these directions for quite a
while I mean about a century now and
there are some interesting things we
could say and but really not directly
you know interesting from physics but
maybe a more interesting for CS math so
these are the two different things that
we will say and well at least we have
two different people for the two talks
ok so physics physics hat so statistical
physics so I assume everyone here knows
about statistical physics but just in
case you know statistical physics 101 so
this is my favorite book by the way by a
fine man which is with you know one of
the physics hero of the 20th century and
so if you open this book the first page
is vector
oh say is everything like very fine man
like the key principle assessed meg is
as follow if you have any possible state
and will want when then each of them can
be you know property to be one of the
state is given by this formula this is
called energy this is a Boltzmann
constant and this is a temperature
that's it and z is just a normalization
so I assume you're all okay with us so
we usually call bit as investor perature
and we don't keep the kb and many right
lads this is a fundamental law of
statistical mechanics the submit
aesthetical mechanic in the sense the
entire field is ever you are trying to
demonstrate vessel you you go from
physics principal and you show that this
is true which by the way is still you
know i'm not sure what this is true we
believe it strongly but there's no serum
that say this is true oh you are using
this and you are playing it to gas
liquids superconductors quantum
mechanics whatever to say something at
the resting about the walk okay so now
you know everything about statistical
mechanics it's a wonder that we need a
full book format so what do we need what
do what do we want as a physicist right
so we have a system with enviable no
it's a vector position if you want all
speeds or something and we have a cost
function or an energy okay so what do
you want we want sampling obviously we
want to have some configuration because
you know if you give us enough sample
configuration with a correct boltzmann
wait you know we can compute the energy
density for instance so you know average
energy divided by the number of viable
of something like the variance of the
energy which is something we call the
specific heat everything so mostly what
we want is a good sampler you give this
to my room to my friend in the physics
department they are happy and they will
be happy to forgot from where I came
from you know don't tell us the math
give us as a machine that would be happy
and pretty much this is it so what's
thing which is important is a physicist
interested in large system and it's not
because we are picky or something is
just you know we try to model i don't
know like gasps what the particle of gas
in this room and they have a lot of them
i mean 10 to the 30-something so we
cannot approximate it with 100 particle
of 200 we really need a lot and that's
it so there is you know we really want
asymptotic prediction and you will see
here but I you know physicist will turn
to work with e divided by M so not the
total energy but energy density and we
are interested in to you no limits
synthetic limits of such quantities
counting so of course you know counting
is important but and that what i already
mentioned a bit i mean in the physics
context you know you don't really need Z
and of course if you can compute it okay
it's great but Z doesn't correspond to
anything interesting as as a physics
problem it's not something but
correspond to living reality what is
interesting is log z and not even log z
is log z divided by the number of
particle and not even less but what we
really want to know is asymptotic value
of this quantity if it exists but you
think about it is usually exists is that
what physicists says and you really want
to add you know the synthetic formula
for the viscosity which we call the free
energy and this is really the growl of
everything I mean if you have the energy
will appear everything because this is
what you know but correspond to a
physics object I mean it's
thermodynamics free energy is what we
call a potential it's really important
so you know that's important because of
course you know it kind of says that the
kind of bounds you can give on the a
really important I mean if something
which is just a multiplicative it's
perfectly fine so the way people do this
most of the time is as follow you try to
estimate the energy density for very you
know many dump attempt
as many of you can do and then you do
this little I mean it's very simple to
demonstrate very little bit of algebra
it's called thermodynamic integration
it's something that of course is not
original at all but this is really the
one or one thing but everyone will do
right so you try to estimate the energy
at the many values you integrate and you
get the free energy and this is what
it's done in ninety nine percent of of
the walk so why do we do all this well
most of the time we are interested in
phase transition and phase transition
it's you know it's a wall but everyone
use but in physics is as a very precise
meaning we cannot just say oh well you
know the system is like this and when I
change it a bit and now it's like that
if you have a phase transition it means
you have a sharp change that occurs at a
very precise value of the parameter for
instance in all what I'm saying it will
means you tune the rest beta okay and
this free energy there's some to take
one as a matter of fact as a
non-linearity city this is what we call
a phase transition is not just a change
of behavior it's a sharp change of
behavior it's very important and one of
the reason we are interested in
extrapolating to n going to infinity is
what its part I mean it's easy to see
that this is analytic so let's cannot
have any year then is finite this is an
analytic function nothing can happen so
this is why we are already interested
into extrapolating to n going to
infinity and what do we do well
obviously you know Monte Carlo methods
and probably metropolis is dominating
ninety percent or more of landscape in
Tata got physic service is what people
okay so this is what the physicist want
and now let me make a you know brief
comment on the difference maybe between
physicist and mathematician and people
in computer science and let's say if you
like math and computer of science you
know I mean you think about the
adversary there is this very bad evil
guy who is here and he wants to beat you
and everything you try you know is
making such a way that the worst thing
one
will happen to you where is this
murphy's low but anything you try or if
anything you can think that could happen
bad will happen so you have to beat it
and it makes sense i mean i understand
that you know it's it's a perfectly
normal attitude and I don't know what
Freud would say about it okay yeah now
physicists are not quite like this and
they believe and they walk sheep damn
nature right i mean they think that
there is a unifying principle and
everything is beauty and everything that
should be nice so everything which is
nice some of us to be true otherwise you
know life would be unfair and you know
life is not unfair as we all know so
somehow you know physicists tends to be
more sloppy about such things and let's
say that you know we are not by agent
and frequentist in someone in some sense
so this is just psychology and I took
these two slides from Chris more but I
think this is true and in some sense
this is this is telling a lot of things
in you know that explain why they
attacked problem in a different way so
what do they do first of all well very
specific instances right first of all I
mean we work in physics with finite
dimensional object we like to put things
on the plane we like if we have a
lattice or so a network we like it to be
a lattice or 2d lattice or 3d lattice
not because we like lattices just
because you know life isn't through 2d
or 3d for differently time of 10 if you
include the strings but it's a finite
dimensional object so most of the work
is usually done in you know for graph
that you can embed into or 3d lattices
however there have been many works on
complete or random graph and there will
be more on the rest later by lenka and
this is maybe water lasting for our
audience and the reason why is typically
it's really weird is because people
realize that they have maybe some good
approximate tools to solve problems on
on sequence of chess graph and they call
it mean field theory and what does you
know what
will do is to say okay let's try to see
what up in a random graph and then let's
hope the same opinion 3d and you know
it's kind of crazy way to think if you
think about it and and then you know
like Easter way of statistical mechanics
is 50 years of trying to yo start from a
min field or random graph and trying to
guess what this event will be in three
dimension 3ds its we are the way of
thinking but this is what what we have
done we I mean sister people in my field
so this is really important because it
explains the attitude of physicists with
common now and this is more connected to
this you know adversary against them
nature the typical resource Wars case
and physicist really really are not you
know the amount is not into works cases
already think about typical and a
typical object on you have a
distribution and you look what is a
typical event and usually we try to walk
in such a way that typical mean average
which is you know not always the case
but this is often what is going on so
this is really important because it's a
very stronger difference okay by the way
the fact that you know if you do
typically the same but average one is
something called save of self averaging
in physics and that's by no mean
navigant property but so now mixing time
so mixing time when you do monte carlo
it's often you just don't know it so
what do you do I mean you have to do
your simulation you cannot wait until
your mathematician friends is telling
you you have to run for that long and
it's not easy right so for instance this
is a nice picture that was given to me
by a male colleague young girl out in in
Paris so this is a two dimensional have
this problem right with just a bunch of
discs and they cannot overlap this is a
Monte Carlo simulation in which you
start from that and you do okay
many steps and you go that is what you
see you have done you know sample Monte
Carlo you try to move something except
project you know it hopefully symbolism
is it good is it not good doesn't look
good right i mean these are two same
disk and actually it's pretty much still
very much correlated and what do we do I
mean you know we just don't know what we
should do at this time so what
physicists do most of the time is to you
know well usually they do some empirical
tests it's not always very clean but
it's really hard to come on you know to
invent some very good test in Monte
Carlo so this day some people are
actually trying to do a very clean
simulation so for instance the only
account we did the simulation is really
interested in applying with the coupling
from the past technique actually did it
work so this is great because then you
you're something which you know it's a
good population in practices of em very
hard so for instance for best problem
what they end up using is to try to
measure the typical angle between two
two particles yeah you see that it's
actually called something that do not
change and when the angle are completely
I mean the macroscopic one so the one of
the rate overall variable of completely
turn they say okay this is fine so it
makes sense that this is a good quantity
but it's still a miracle ok so what
physicists will do is to try to plot 20
40 50 different what it is and take the
worst one and okay well that's what you
do something very important about mixing
time well when you compute it this is to
again tend to forget about the worst
case and this is not because we are
careless is that most of the times the
worst case is not important at all and
lenka will discuss more about this in
the context of random graph later let
your I see something I repeat many times
but it's really something which is in
the mind of physicists now prefect on
matters sometime I discuss with my a
mathematician colleagues and they
well I have this algorithm movies which
is you know running in oh el to
something and this guy invented an
algorithm which is running with the same
exponent of course the prefactor is
better but who cares it's a pre factor
we care ok because if I do simulation
for a year and I don't but there are
people do and if you tell me that I need
to do to any ten years when I cannot do
it because my slam I not slay my spirit
is student will be careful three years
and I cannot you know and so perfect
i'll do matter and this is one of the
reason but you know if you tell me that
I should run 10 billion step while the
truth you know it's not tight it's easy
it's 1,000,000,000 step this is
important I mean I really need to know
that if I want to do a protocol
simulation okay phase transition of
thought they are hard to detect and if
you look to what people do in physics
when we use this simulation really a
huge amount of work is spent just trying
to kind of guess what will that buy that
add infinity for n equal I don't know
100 200 300 400 so it looks some kind of
wizardry magic and actually there is no
it's not merely spot magic parts i
answer is a lot of things that we know
about how to do a how to play this game
there is this beautiful Theory called
finite size scaling but this is what we
try to do I mean you will see a lot of
you know increasing size and try to
guess what the limiting behavior wise
sometime we can do it and now we have a
very good understanding of I don't know
electrons and liquid gas transition
sometimes we cannot so we still have no
idea you know what were the glass is
okay because we can simulate it I mean
we can simulated 100-200 particle is not
enough okay so what I want to do now for
the last ten minute is to maybe be a bit
more concrete and discuss let's say two
different problem and tell what people
do right just again there I level talk
so one of the thing which is amazingly
popular and by amazingly i mean really
amazingly popular is this thing called
parallel tampering so it has many names
some people call it simulated tampering
a replica exchange monte carlo again
it's not clear for me we should be
credited I think I mean it was
introduced by something wrong but then
they have been some variation and so I I
driver side everyone here and I'm
probably forgetting people so it's
really something very powerful and this
is how it works so if you want to
simulate one system so you use metro
police roll fine now you do many copy of
the system and copy you know many copies
is not nice so many replicas of the
system I don't replica of the system you
have like 10 of them they are the same
system and you simulate the 10 of them
separately at different temperature ok
might be a good idea anyway because if
you want to compute the free energy you
will need to know the energy a different
value and then integrate row what I do
it and now all right and now what you do
and this isn't arresting thing you try
to exchange the temperature between two
replicas from time to time you take you
know the system which is running at a
plurality of 1.2 and this one a 1.3 and
you change the to temperature according
to the metro police roll it is just
metropoulos when you you know switch
temperature so this is still following
detailed balance so why is it a good
idea well you know it's how to say and
the only thing I can tell you is make a
drawing so this is telling your match
analytical work varies in the direction
the ideas of us follow imagine you have
two replicas so you simulate the system
so you know this is a configuration
space one is here when it is are two
different system
this one is hot so it's read this one is
a cool so it's blue and you know we are
kind of locked in the local minima so it
is as follow I mean if you are lucky
sometimes you would exchange the
temperature now this one being hot you
would expect that you would visit you
know the configuration with higher
energy when you will diffuse where then
if you exchange again your butt yeah
imagine right so it's not just cartoon
because one of the most used tool in
optimization is simulated annealing
which is exactly using this and we know
that if we run simulator nailing slow
enough it will work eventually but if
you look at this problem and that kind
of techniques it has been you know huge
huge impact in science I mean really
it's something that works not in the
sense that it approximate polynomially
something and it doesn't in the sense
that if someone has a problem and you
must to solve it because it's important
for I don't know a neural network to
turn a neural network on you might
understand protein folding of your
concert or that kind of thing that's
important too and yeah that is giving
something the truth is or whether if you
look to what what you can say about it
i'm in which is not much for that sense
what is you know if i have a problem how
many replicas should i use which
temperature should i choose of em so
there is a folklore for us people say
well you know you should use the log of
the number of something and temperature
should be distributed evenly and but
these are just it's just folklore
folclore it's good but you know I it's
something on which I believe if you
compare the number of results for what
kind of algorithm with how much it is
used in practice it's it's it's I think
it's a pdn of probably a lot of things
should be done in this direction so
what's one of them
the other thing I want to mention and
now it's maybe going in the other
direction is I want to discuss out some
ideas but you really came from laughs at
the huge impact in physics recently was
this idea of balance condition versus
detailed balance so we heard about
detailed balance I mean detailed balance
is essentially this condition here okay
so if I remove this this is detailed
balance property to be somewhere and to
jump somewhere else will be the same as
the property to be there and to come
back now this is great it was presented
yesterday and doesn't aim reversibility
and this is a good name did and but you
don't need this right i mean if you want
your back of chain to to converge you
you can relax rest and what you really
need is that I mean you can you need you
can have a much weaker condition so if
you want to think about what it means in
terms of arrows detailed balance means
you know that in terms of flags so let's
converse the flags north or flow if you
want you know going where should be the
same as going there so when you do
detailed balance you are taking all your
different configuration in your state
univ face face and you're saying okay
sir you know i should have the same flow
greenville and going back but you don't
need that what you need is a global
condition so this is fine and this is
fine as long as you set up the
probability correctly and that kind of
goes I'm where you know you have
something completely directional are
called maximum global balance and this
is interesting because in many ways this
is not a natural thing to do to detail
balance if you think about when you are
smelling coffee during the polls and for
instance the fact that you can smell
coffee it's because the way things work
is not by detailed balance if you would
have to wait until your particle from
coffee will diffuse randomly in a
totally reversible like this and goes to
your nose you will have to wait really a
long time the reason why you don't have
to wait a long time is because in the
air there are some
cease and there is some turbulence and
it's actually carrying in very good
directions everywhere and so mixing
inside gases is much faster than just if
you do some a slow slow growth of
diffusion process so it does you know it
probably makes sense who try to do
things like vests in Monte Carlo as well
and there have been a lot of work this
direction for instance the passage icon
is made very nice algorithm so my friend
physics department we already interested
by this and I'm showing this it's a work
from Ghana coat again four in the fifth
Department in ens we wanted to look at
very old physics question how do things
melt in two dimensions believe it or not
that's something in which people still
do not agree or at least they were not
agreeing five years ago and what do you
do that case you do simulation so again
you come back to your two-dimensional
none of a non-overlapping a sphere model
and we know the following if you have a
dense packing you can go up to ninety
percent backing and it's a result from
Lancome you know and then you do some
simulation what you will see that the
system do not crystallize in the sense
that you do not have long-range order if
you know what the particle is here you
cannot really predict but the particle
is here your ability to predict is
decaying like a polo okay however you
have a long-range directional order in
the sense that if things are like this
here you know that at any distance
things will be still aligned so you have
a long-range orientational order and
Nancy big decay of positional order okay
week invest a solid phase now if you go
to a face with a very low density you
have a liquid phase well you have no
love at all I mean after a finite length
you are losing both orientational and
positional order so how do you go from
one to the other and people have been
fighting fighting and fighting for years
about this or decades since 60s well
even the thirties if you want actually
and it's not clear it has not been clear
and what was the discussion was okay
people agree there is a solid-phase
people agree there was this liquid phase
and then they some people said okay you
go from here to here in a kind of weird
transition and some other people said no
no no no no you first have a transition
to exotic which is a so called
continuous transition and when these are
continuous question to liquid and
exacting could be something really weird
in which like a liquid you don't have
positional order but somehow you still
have a long range order well let's say
an algebraic day care of our national
order but mean it's exacting the order
you know if you know that guys are
aligned like this the ability to predict
if they are still aligned with the same
angle will decay with Apollo and you
know people have been debating for us
for years until until my collector and
student the manual michelle and at the
time it was also attend are now so now
we will tell jess i give at people
describing in mathematics and using in
Monte Carlo they said not forget but
metropolis and they say okay let's try
to see what you should do so metal
polish workers like this you try to move
a particle ah it's a valid best one
reject so I said okay now let's try to
do something which is respecting global
balance and which will be not reversible
so as I says as follow you take this
particle you move it here and now we
touch this one so at first you decide I
don't care I want to move from best
distance okay so you move here your
block it's okay you stop and you tell
the next one to move from the same
distance then you move here you are
about average guy your block you move as
guy from the Sun distant and so on and
so forth okay and if you repeat this and
every time you have to decide appear way
the length and the angle you can show
that this is respecting global balance
you don't have any rejection you accept
always what is going on so it's a
perfect valid multicolored go either
it's very simple now just using that
suddenly where were able to simulate
much larger size we were about to
simulate system a million particle
comedian is not you know it's not 10 to
the 50 but the million is not bad and
suddenly they would say this is a true
phase diagram they could actually for
the first time and service question I'll
do things melt into dimension okay so
let me ax so basically what they say
that not only there is an exotic phase
so the people we say the reason we're
wrong but even the people who say there
was an exact if phase we are wrong
because they miss the fact that there is
a region of volume fraction in which you
have to face coexisting which is super
call it's something that happens when
you have the first order transition like
when ice is transforming into water and
at the kind of fantastic simulation that
they could do so you have really a
million particle here and the color code
is still in use orientational order so
this is you know you have something
splitted into here you have a liquid you
don't have any you know la grange things
are red here but when they are green
here so this is really liquid and here
you have an exotic phase well everything
is blue so you're a very long range or
still the same orientational order and
the fact that they coexist is a proof
that you have an exacting liquid phase
coexistence and that you know that was
really really something that could not
have been done with any of your
algorithm I think it's very important to
see that you know sample Monte Carlo
I'll go with a nasty news and tagged
evaluation you know can have a huge
impact in physics now they actually
applying that kind of algorithm to any
algorithm with a continuous degree of
freedom and it seems to be extremely
powerful and I'm really impressed by
what we have okay so I think it's time
to stop here so to summarize I wanted to
say that physicist of different minds
let's say the way they see this problem
they tend to work more with typical
event but most cases so this is true for
instances for starting condition for the
viable look at and
and so on and so forth these are strong
and faces on trying to reach laughs
sizes and to extrapolate at least two
large sizes because this is what we want
to do and I discussed to a different
problem which you know that was very by
highly biased by the best choice so
parallel tampering and I wanted to
discuss with you know I've always a bad
break the tie balance because I think
this is something that is a game changer
all right so I'm done and finger did
lenka the next slide
so I will go back from physics to a
problem that we already heard about
yesterday and today and that's counting
colorings on graphs but I will look at
it in the same spirit as was undress
montanari store yesterday so on random
graphs so that's and I will present you
the physics picture so most of it will
not be rigorous but then it's beautiful
so we should care about it and one way
to care about it is trying to prove it
right so that somehow the motivation so
this picture I i took that i took the
idea from lassie yesterday is due to
many people so at the beginning here I
put the names and then then these people
will forgive me if I don't repeat them
on the slides where they should actually
be so this this this slide I prepared my
talk before seeing andreas talked
yesterday but this is not showing
anything but this this I did there
yesterday because it's pretty much the
same slide as andrea was showing why do
we care about random and instances so we
can look at them as a first step towards
modeling typical instances another point
is that they have this intrigue of
mathematical properties you really
interesting things happen so that's why
I am interested in it from a physics
point of view and Florence said that we
look at random instances because they
are solvable they correspond to this
mean field models for our physics
systems and that's the easy case in
physics so in front of physicists or in
front of my physics colleagues I'm
actually doing something very trivial
but in front of mathematicians I'm doing
something impossible because it's not
rigorous tourism between these words so
that's that's also a reason and these
are just the names of the methods I will
not be able to go into the details of
the metals but i will present you the
picture and more practical motivation
here is that understanding what's
happening on random ideas has led to
several algorithmic ideas that would you
know that would just not not come
probably otherwise so much later so
that's why it's also use so i will
present you the picture on the example
of the graph coloring because we already
heard
about it everybody knows about it but
here he our list other problems you know
where the same picture on random
instances is relevant it's it's
basically the same thing with some
variants so the satisfiability
constraint satisfaction problems
independent sets if I just pick those
that we also heard about but also some
machine learning information theory
problems that that are relevant so graph
coloring just to set the the notation
basically so I mean the no canonical
problem of graph coloring where I have a
graph nodes have colors and neighbors do
not want to have the same color but I
will also look at two variants one would
be I guess it was called in the previous
called weighted colorings that if i call
SI the color of note I so then this
Kronecker Delta function will be telling
me if two neighbors because I NJ here r
is an edge so they are neighbors have
the same color so we'll just those that
are the edges that are not happy i will
be waiting them with some factor
exponential minus B does of this how we
usually do it in physics because then
the beta is the inverse temperature
temperature being the actual temperature
in the common sense for us for instance
less he had 1 plus gamma which was my e
to the beta and another variant that
Andre also mentioned that is really
interesting will be so one case of
graphs I will be looking at it's just
random browser this range around
dubrow's another case of grass will be
displayed graphs so how do i create
those to create those actually start
with the color with new nodes that are
colored but there are no edges yet and
then I throw the edges but I throw them
in such a way that I don't I don't put
in monochromatic edges so I choose them
at random between those that are not
monochromatic so that's you know why not
that's a glass of random grass and
they're really interesting so now you
win in a physics port so in terms of
what wrong was saying what am i
interested in when I say I want to count
the colorings so first of all I'm
interested in large systems so n will be
the size of the graph and we are always
interested
n is very large when just to define the
average degree if m is the number of
edges then then this is the average
degree of the graph so I will be looking
at every degree that is fixed because
that's where whereas n goes to infinity
because that's the interesting regime so
one you're really easy thing that we
could call you're related to counted
coloring is so i compute average over
the random graphs of the number of
proper colorings of that graph and then
i take the log and i divide by n so this
i can do there is a bracket missing here
so just imagine a bracket here so this
is really easy to evaluate actually you
just what you just need to take you have
Q to the end possible colorings if you
don't take into account of the proper or
not and then you just multiplied by the
probability that the given random color
ring is appropriate coloring of the
graph which will be nothing else that
that 1 minus 1 over Q power the number
of edges ok and that's what gives you
this expression so you know that's
that's that's really see we are really
more interested in to we know this these
names come from physics into similar
thing but the expectation is not inside
the log but outside to look so that's
what we are really and I put the plus +
1 here just in case if the number of
colorings is 0 that I don't have a
problem with the definition of the log
right but that will not change anything
a if I take this one over and the limit
will not change if I put the plus one
hero so and this one I cannot write a
simple formula ok because it doesn't
have a simple formula but we came the
methods we have in physics allow us to
calculate it exactly and this is so this
is just a sketch that I did on a piece
of paper ok but I could get a code that
they've always these numbers exactly so
this is what happens so this is the
average degree here and here i am
plotting the entropy so the violet line
which is just a linear line here this is
for comparison this any old entropy this
simply expression that i explained you
and you see that the every degree is
just here so it's just the linear line
ok fine goes from 1 to minus infinity so
and
this quenched entropy that is the one we
are really interested in that's the
orange line here and it's doing
something like this so notably there is
a well-defined point where it's where
you know up to which it is exactly equal
to this expression and then it is
something else so this point we call it
ck of the console Couchman Andrea called
it alpha C yesterday of cs condensation
so this is a phase transition in the
mathematical statistical physics sense
because this function has a non
analyticity as this ck and that's how we
define phase transitions so there is a
phase transition at ck and then this
curve actually has goes to some finite
value and here it jumps to zero meaning
that this is always typically this is
zero so there are no colorings in this
regime here and so this defines this
color ability threshold which andrea for
satisfiability yesterday called alpha s
so I already have one phase transition
and one threshold I will get to the
distinction between stretch hold phase
transition in like two slides or
something like that so that's already
interesting or how do we what's what's
happening there so so now I put this
picture with bubbles that under I showed
you yesterday inch and this is so this
is my color ability threshold this is
the scouts one temperature so these two
were on the previous slide and I add two
more it will be the dynamical transition
and unicity threshold now I should
explain maybe a bit better these blobs
okay so each so each square is here like
different every degree so this axis is
the average degree is growing right and
so now take the first square now every
pixel would be a coloring now a blue
pixel is a proper coloring and white
pixel is an improper coloring okay and
this is a represent this is just a
cartoon but it's a representation of
half the space of proper coloring looks
like so there is so when the average
degree is really small geometric is just
one block then when it gets past this
you
Missa tee threshold it's still one blob
that takes measure one of all the
colorings but there are also smaller
blobs around that are you know that are
taking sub sub bleeding fraction of the
colorings but they are there and then
there is this dynamical transition that
is defined that this big blob splits
into exponentially many blobs so to
actually cover measure one of our
colorings you would have to take
exponentially many of these clusters and
then there is this trans phase
transition where the entropy changes
where the entropy departs from this
simple and yield expression and thats
related to the fact that it's only
finite number of this blobs that will
start to count and then there are no
proper colorings anymore so that's the
color ability treasure so here these are
the five basic phases and these these
these thresholds between them are really
sharply defined and I can give you some
numbers so interestingly in some cases
like three side or three coloring this
one and this one go inside so this face
is sometimes missing but for four and
more k sath for more coloring and you
know there's a solo g of cases this one
is there so here now I want to give you
a some values and now talk about
something that Andhra didn't really
mention but that we are really
interested you're here because the very
name of the program is counting so what
about counting and sampling was the
consequence of this picture for counting
and sampling so first of all the way and
redefined the clusters was very
geometrical he said something like I
will walk a fine two solutions to be
close to each other if they differ to
proper colorings to be close to each
other if they differ in small number of
variables then i define equivalence
classes on this so that's one definition
which I don't like too much because it's
not quite tied to what we really mean in
physics by these clusters a definition
that is much better but a bit more way
is that each of these clusters is
actually part of a subspace that metro
police knew
montecarlo would sample uniformly in
linear time or log linear time if you
care about the law right so so you can
think of these clusters or Bob's as sub
sub spaces where multicolored would
simply uniformly fast but it would not
to jump from one to another would take
exponential time so so this
understanding of these clusters instead
of Monte Carlo me if you know
equilibration time or sampling time it's
much more intuitive and that's what
somehow is more relevant or so for
physics so that's what I'm saying here
and now you can and now we can interpret
this picture in terms of this Monte
Carlo mixing time so if you define
mixing time as you know something has to
be true for every initial condition then
you will be mixing in this phase but not
in this one because if you happen to
start in this small blog you will never
jump to the big blob so you will not be
mixing in this strict definition of
mixing time on the other hand this
threshold here is physically totally not
interesting for the coloring problem so
tip so I'm putting it here just to do
the distinction but it's not interesting
it's not even a phase transition in the
physic sense so what we would like to do
when we define mixing time is to say oh
I start from from a configuration that
is uniform from the measure that I care
to be simply in the first place so that
one would for sure be in this big blob
and then I look if it if it equilibrates
and by that I would mean it covers
almost all the space not strictly
speaking all the space just measure one
of the space and if I do it this way
then I would be mixing up to this
dynamical transition and if I really
take AG large grab and I care running
metropoulos on it and I look how long
and prickly and I put some empirical
criteria that flora was mentioning and I
try to evaluate what is
the mixing time using this empirical two
criteria I will actually find quite
independently of what actually Monte
Carlo Markov chain i'm using and what
empirical criteria i'm using i will find
that the mixing time is diverging in the
sense that it becomes super linear at
this dynamical transition and so that's
what makes it really interesting this
this dynamical transition so that's one
that we really really care about and in
physics this transition would correspond
to the classy transition so when your
window glass is not the liquid any more
it becomes a glass so so now here in
this regime it's hopeless because to
jump from one class to to another i know
that i would take exponential time and
okay but this is you know this is the
intuition I proving something like that
it's something really interesting but
the conjecture is that this face is
truly hard that the mixing time would be
exponentially no matter what you do of
course I mean this is your conjecture me
proving something about that this is
really the challenge so and nothing much
happens at this phase transition with
the mixing this wills and here I have
nothing anymore to sample and this
picture is here just to say you know the
Sigma would be the entropy like
logarithm of the number of these
clusters and the blue one would be how
many clusters do you need to take to
cover measure one of your space and the
valid one would be how many of them do
you have total also if you care about
the subdominant one so you have so they
disappear all of them disappear at the
color ability threshold and this this
line defines the dynamical and couchman
transitions and then the unicity here is
dashed because we are not really because
maybe something more complicated is
happening here so all right so that was
about sampling now my first variant was
no introducing the temperature because
so far was sampling proper colorings now
if I introduce the weights you know with
this dynamical transition in this
councilman temperature that couchman
transition nothing much will happen they
will just have some
dependence on the temperature but the
picture will be pretty much the same of
the color ability threshold that will
completely be irrelevant at finite
temperature that's purely that's a
notion that only has sense if i look at
the proper colorings and this unicity
threshold it can be defined at finite
temperature but as I said I mean it's
actually very very hard to even devise a
numerical experiment which would
pinpoint where it is so it's you know
it's it's irrelevant for the properties
that we care about in physics so
physically we ignore the blue line and
then we say above the violet line this
is liquid phase in between here this is
a dynamical glass and below this orange
is the ideal glass and this you know and
some window glasses or some magnetic
glasses or some materials like that
actually respect this phase diagram
alright and yeah in the folkloric when
we do monte carlo simulations in physics
basically the violet line would be
defined as the empirically measured
equilibration time diverging so you buy
definite by its definition above it
sampling is easy and below it same thing
is very hard we have no idea how to
sample in sub exponential time in
practice and here just a little note
about so why do I call something
threshold inside something a phase
transition so in physics when we talk
about the phase transition both is just
some sharp property of the system but
the phase transition must be related to
divergence of some length all right and
that's that's something very important
some so for instance the transition from
from liquid to vapor is is related to
some you add the transition some very
large clusters of the vapor or the
liquid creating and this can be you know
this can be measured and has some
physical consequences so we've always in
physics care about these diverging
correlation links so it's useful to say
that you know the color ability and
this unisa t it's not the phase
transition it doesn't have a good
diverging length but this dynamical
transition has and the length that
diverges is called the point to set
length so that would be a correlation so
on this random graph they look locally
like a tree line like a tree so you can
define a neighborhood of a note and that
will be a tree and the correlation
between the boundaries of that tree and
that node is a well difference so the
length up to which the boundary is
correlated to the root is the corolla is
the point to set correlation length and
this length would diverge as you
approach this dynamical phase transition
so that's how it is defined and the
scouts mark phase transition that would
be just the correlation between two
nodes so our two notes that are far away
from each other correlated or not and
starting from the scouts man point they
are because with finite probability two
configurations would appear to be in one
blob and everything that is in one of
these clusters is correlated so that's
okay just a note there is a very nice
paper by Andrew and key and where they
prove some inequalities for these
lengths and times just look so now I
want to spend the rest of my time on
this planted coloring so 10 minutes so
so once again what it is so I take a
random string so I have notes and I
color them and then I choose edges only
after I choose edges at random such that
you I don't put edges between the same
colors that's how i create micro all
right so why is this interesting so
there are at least two reasons why is
this interesting first of all it can be
seen as a parody game of statistical
inference problem the string I started
with is the signal the fact where I put
or not the edges is a kind of
measurement of that signal because if I
put an edge it means that the two nodes
were different so this is telling me
something about the coloring i started
with right so in all settings where you
have some signal and then use measure it
in
way and then from the measurements you
want to infer the signal there's this
kind of problem right and statistical
inferences of course very important and
people in computer science use Monte
Carlo to do inference in practical
problems and it's basically the
ninety-five percent of Monte Carlo in
computer science is used to for exactly
this to do inference in in in bias
probably in Bayesian probability well
because computing market because
basically doing optimally inference is
equivalent to computing marginals of the
posterior probability so basically to
counting so if you can sample if you can
count you can also do interference so
that's what we care about and planted
gallery is an example of this problem so
that's one reason and second reason is
that mathematically this problem is
actually simple to prove things about it
for instance for for a very particular
reason that will that's what that will
that I will expand on the next slide so
first of all you I cared about counting
coloring on the random graphs so now
let's count colorings on the planted
crops so that's the same picture I just
edit the blue line which would be the
entropy on the planted graphs so nothing
changes up to this Couchman transition
and then so up to this councilman
transition the num the logarithm of the
number of colorings is exactly the same
on the planet and random graphs and
after the scouts man transition is
bigger than this naive annealed
expression that you might think is a
good good first idea of what could it
possibly be so this is how it looks and
in terms of my blobs how it looks you
know nothing much changes I just adhere
a point which is the plant which should
be one pixel but if it was really one
pixel you wouldn't see it so that's the
planted configuration bit bigger so
that's just one pixel it's not a blog
actually okay and is here and then it's
in one of the clusters and then discuss
their survives and is bigger than all
the rest and then it survives him even
when all the rest is not
anymore so what's really important here
is the scotsman transition again and it
has the following property when the
average degree is smaller than this
number then actually this planted
configuration behaves exactly in the
same way as a random configuration so if
i ask myself what does it mean for
inference it means that inference is
impossible there was just information
theoretically there is no information
about the configuration i started with
in the ensemble of edges so information
theoretically nothing can be done but
it's also interesting for us if we care
about Monte Carlo sampling and we could
ask you know it also means that this
configuration behaves exactly in the
same way as any other equilibrium
configuration so for instance if we want
to start multikill already a clear ated
while we generate the planted graph and
which if we started in this
configuration and this is what some of
us would call a worm start and this is
correct as long as the average t as long
as the graph was large and every degree
was smaller than this councilman
transition this is really interesting
and when you want to prove something
about how these blobs look like well
it's really useful to have actually a
configuration that for sure is in one of
your typical blobs because then you can
do math around that configuration and
that simplifies a lot of things so
that's it and then so in the cases that
I mentioned when this dynamical
transition and couchman transition
coincide so where this face is not
present then what happens above the
couch man transition for the inference
is just that Monte Carlo will be simple
the mixing time will be fine it and
we'll find the you know the correct
marginals of the corresponding posterior
whenever the average degree is bigger
than this Couchman so statistical
inference will be no statistically optic
like information theoretic a optimal
interference will be easy will be doable
and you can just do it by running your
favorite Markov chain on this problem so
that's that's that's the simpler
situation you just divide the
space of your parameter order some
parameter that you are changing into two
way into two cases either influence is
impossible or is doable and you know how
to do it with your favorite Monta cow so
but that's the case is where the ck is
CD but in the generic case when these
two phase transitions do not go inside
there is another phase transition
happening for the planted case that we
call a spin odel transition so it would
be somewhere here here i put the scale
links right so maybe i can mention them
so the average degree for the unicity
threshold is something like cube and
that's you know this due to delta that
for delta that we heard about this
morning that's that's the same regime
where things you know where things
happen and where this kind of strong
mixing times can be proven now the
interesting thing for a for a sampling
when q is large happens when the average
degree is about q lo q so you know march
after them then this color ability and
couchman transition happen about twice
as much so you see that this phase is
quite large and then in the planted
coloring at about Q square something
else happens and this new phase that
arises is actually hard so if I look if
I tell you again what will be the
Montecarlo doing in this generic
situation when CD is not ck is so before
ck planted equal random interference
impossible you know you can sample here
you cannot simple here anyway everything
is as i already told you so but what is
new is here so here Monte Carlo mixing
time would be exponentially large you
would just never for unless you start in
this blog you will never find that the
blob is there and when you cross the
spinodal transition it will if you will
find the correct marginals in linear
time or lobe linear time if you care
about the log so that's really that's a
really fundamental phase transition so
here you know what what actually happens
in this plant it going you know in
physics is really simple you just have a
first order phase transition and on
geometries
just random browse where the surface is
as big as the volume right the boundary
of a tree are as big as the number of
nodes that you have into your twice
smaller or something like that but not
much smaller if you have a cube the
bounder is much smaller than the volume
43 is not true so in geometries like
that a first order phase transition
which is this ck is related to two
spinels its basic you have somehow two
states that coexist one would be you
know the blob with your planted
configuration and the other one would be
the para magnet which is somehow the
average over all the other blobs and and
there is there is a region where they
coexist and and so okay maybe I can
leave if I explain this figure so this
would be logarithm of the partition
function so number of colorings that are
at a given distance from a random
coloring and when that bridge degree is
small you know and you would the true
sampling would like to be at the global
maximum at the of this function and
somehow Monte Carlo body does it starts
at zero and climbs up and if it is stuck
and if and clams climbs up and if it is
if if the function goes down well then
it stays up all right so here it stays
up and it's correct because it's the
maximum here it stays up and it's
correct is still the maximum here is
this up is still correct because it's
the maximum even though there is another
maximum but it's lower so most of the
mass is still carried here but here is
when it comes wrong the Monte Carlo
start stays here stays here starts here
and stays there because it only can go
up but there is another point which is
higher that's the one that you would
like to find and to find it you would
have to jump this kind of a barrier and
this would take your exponential time
and you just never find it so this is
what's causing the heart face and then
this flattens so you go up and you
actually realize that you can go up and
here you just go up easily so this kind
of a first order phase transition is not
now I skipped one flight is something
that happens in the planted coloring but
also something that happens in many
other statistical inference problems and
here i just listed few were it was
identified planted go straight
satisfaction and some clustering
problems and low rank matrix
factorizations and pca error correcting
codes compressed sensing many problems
of interest with many applications where
if you do some if you look at ensemble
of some random instances you can
identify this hard face so what it means
that here you know inference is
impossible Monte Carlo would find you
the right margins but the margins are
just saying I don't know in which group
why should be or I don't know anything
there is no information so you don't
care so much then there is a phase where
Monte Carlo finds the true margins and
the truth marshals are related to what
you are looking for so you are happy and
then there is a phase where one day gala
will just tell you hmm to me it seems
like there is no information but
actually there is information if you ran
it for exponentially long it will tell
you the right thing but so this is and
we see Andy's somehow boundaries of
these phases like we know how to compute
them in a list of problems and there are
you more and more of them appearing
basically every month there would be
some some new paper etc but so far it's
it's a mess I mean we would definitely
it will definitely be nice if we started
to him some some kind of beautiful
classifications as we have in the
complexity in the in the counting
complexity or complete algorithmic
complexity this would be really nice
right but already already in these
problems where we can compute these
things it's really helpful to have you
know you know where things are possible
and you know up to where you can hope
that simple algorithms will work
sometimes you compute this transition
and you just realize okay my current
algorithms work up to there so then
while I'm happy and there is no point
writing hundred more papers on better
algorithms because they are basically
already be optimal on the other hand
when you compute this fate in this
transition and you realize that your
current algorithms are still far away
from it well then then you see the ball
there is still some space you know there
is
fundamental reasons why I shouldn't be
able to improve the algorithms and
sometimes these gaps are big and
sometimes when you would have some
heuristic algorithms that would work
well but no proofs but having basically
the computation of this phase transition
would help some of our mathematician
colleagues and some of them are sitting
in the audience to actually prove that
some of the algorithms work up to this
bouncing and get actually much better
algorithmic bounds for some of these
important problems so so that's it so my
conclusion is basically no this is this
is the physics picture and you can
either say you know most of this is not
rigorous I don't care i go to take off
here you could so this is interesting
because we connect this is this is
really intriguing and beautiful we can
try to establish this and understand
what's actually happening and I would
you know I would love to see to have
some mathematically rigorous new theory
that would be that would be sent with
the even definitions of the notions that
would be sensitive to the phase
transitions that we think are really
important and in this case this would be
this dynamical transition and the
spinodal transition those are the most
important because they have they have
direct consequences on when sampling is
practically complicated or not so that's
my conclusion
do you want to connect neurons and then
questions for both of you so I mean you
say these things are vigorous but so
they're not purely based on simulation
other you mean you do calculations what
are the methods that you're using to get
sort of numbers well right so here are
the names of the methods and in practice
Your Honor I yesterday he got the same
question I don't know if it was you
somebody has him the same question so he
started so he so basically how things
work to get to get numbers that don't
come from like very heavy simulations
not from Monte Carlo it's still at the
end it still I need to solve some
numerical equations but not okay in
physics Giorgio's Paris in his last dog
that I so give a nice definition
everything that the computer can solve
under one second is analytical so so
analytical in this sense so so basically
how things would work is that yo dis
random graphs are locally trees so our
first approxi so our first case would be
let's try to take this belief
propagation which is iterative equations
to compute the marginals if the graph
actually was a tree and assume that
what's on the boundary doesn't matter
and see what happens and then we realize
that actually the very definition of the
cluster here if we think about what it
means in physics in terms of the
equilibration time and you know we
always linked the equilibration time to
the correlations to this point to set
correlations and in the way we see it is
that it's one-to-one correspondence if
if we are in a blob then it means that
the boundaries do not matter that so
then it means that this computation that
I was doing on that tree is correct so
basically what we are assuming here that
to describe every single of these blobs
we can use this belief propagation
equations and so here and here it's easy
because here these little blobs here i
can just neglect them because they
don't get the most of the measure and
what do I do here to get some numbers
like how many blobs do I have or hear
how many blows do I have so what I do is
I actually set a art in auxiliary a
graphical model or probabilistic model
where my variables won't be the colors
but will be the messages of this belief
propagation the constraints won't be you
guys cannot have the same colors but
will be the belief propagation equations
need to be satisfied and then I will be
counting how many fixed points of these
belief propagation equations they are
and I will assume that every fixed point
corresponds to one of these blobs and
from this i will get things like how
many clusters of a given size they are
and and you know what is their size and
and things like that so basically the
analytics everything is running and
around you know taking this belief
propagation equations assuming that
belief propagation fixed points
corresponds to the sub spaces where
Monte Carlo would sample fast and this
is this is a natural notion but to make
something about it dislike I have no
idea how one would you start maybe my
colleagues mathematicians did prove
these things also don't have any idea I
don't clusters rather than something
more weighted or I achieved magesh a
message yes what why do you just want to
count the blobs yeah I count them for
instance weighted by their size you know
if I can I can I can basically put the
weights in these calculations in every
once i can do it for something i can
usually do it for for many different
things putting the ways in many
different ways so i would typically
compute your put some like kind of like
ranch parameter like the beta for their
size and for their diameter for their
you know I don't know for their number
of variables of a given Cat of a of a
given color that are in the
configurations you know all kinds of
things so i can compute their size
weight you how many of them they are
forgiven size and things like that
things like that we compute it so it
goes so that you have to do the
methodology is through this tree
approximation and this is on the random
graphs and the tricky maybe first time
first time see tricky point is that the
same kind of calculations also work you
know some of these systems I cited for
instance this compressed sensing is
living for on a fully connected graph
it's not at all a tree like crap and in
this system a similar kind of
assumptions work but the code but you
always need some correlations to be
negligible and sometimes they are
negligible because things are trees and
would I could pick and the loops that
correlate things are far away and
sometimes things are negligible because
I'm so connected and I have so many
neighbors that the influence of my one
neighbor is not so big so that's another
so I was so a usual look for some kind
of correlation DK that i could write
some simpler equations where
correlations that are negligible will be
neglected and which will lead to to some
closed equations the equations to
compute for instance the color ability
threshold and dresser that it's like
three slides and that he doesn't dare to
take it it it's an equation that is it's
a it's a it's a it's a fixpoint equation
for a function so it's not something
very nice i mean proving something about
it if i really want to be done like
analytical it's not really easy but it's
something that mathematical a sauce i
mean i just ask i just take some
iterative method to solve it and i get
six digits of the number easily or
twenty maybe not because it's not that
easy so does that
there's any much more these faces like
for like random bipartite graphs random
bipartite graphs so for coloring I don't
think nothing much would change I mean
42 calories things would change because
you're perverted in the first place so
it would be like planted but so random
by part type would be like if you plant
to color ink that's right bipartite and
planting to coloring that's basically
the same that's the same thing so i
would have to i would have to see what's
happening for three or five coloring
when i plant to coloring so okay nobody
has done the eyes maybe somebody has
done it but it's not published a
calculation like that but for coloring I
don't think that much would happen
because the fact that is bipartite if
you have three and more colors will not
matter much I think but that's so that's
just a guess but something that could be
done but I cannot like give you our
answer straight straight ahead something
that with these methods could be done
this could be described in detail I
don't think anybody has done it
good question
okay thanks